well write them again okay she's doing
this so sociology at the University yeah
are you enjoying that Sara that's not
when you know you get you sit on the
phone and you giving her the dick yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
ha he was probably fingering her right
there nice of you to walk your friend
home I'm really nice a lot of jerks out
there you take advantage of the freshmen
a lot of jerks out there take advantage
of you know drunk freshmen the
awkwardness is realer than spice change
she's like shells about the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] man now you can just sleep in
there's another one its consent videos
its noodling yup I just caught lock the
[ __ ] out of him
[Applause]
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you see what
just happened there he covered her
without her consent
disgusting Savage should ask for
permission what if she gets too out at
night what if she didn't want to be
tucked in I'm one of those people who
doesn't like to sleep with blankets on
okay respect my boundaries you Savage
[Music]
don't be disappointed ah your rapist you
don't think there's a theory out there
that says that if a woman has sex while
she's drunk it's right but if the guy's
also drunk does that mean they're raping
each other just like a thing where like
[Music]
you don't have anything they were both
drunk there and if they had sex what
does is the dude at fault I'm not saying
he was wrong for tucking her in or
whatever but what would have happen
otherwise you guys think it would have
been wrong if they did have sex it's not
like she didn't want to be there while
drunk as always she was like no or this
and that if they had sex what would have
been so wrong about it she was not
passed out there was nothing in a dream
if she wanted it
nothing that would be something wrong
idea but she definitely wanted her upset
yeah seems like you guys are putting all
the responsibility on us to make sure
consent is there which I think everyone
should take responsibility of the men
just as much as the women I know am I
wrong yeah you know I mean they're both
drunk do you want to have sale and have
sex - was not passed out oh yeah
[Music]
by the morning after she father saw him
and even asked for consent to Tucker I'm
watching the pissed
[Music]
something something something that
dreams are made of there's nothing you
can do
still armpit hair and hairy ass legs
what up ho all right oh she wanted to be
something but it wrong you didn't ask
for consent oh I know we were fine
things about fuzzy and then I came home
with you but then you're over here couch
yeah nothing nothing yeah
I don't want to fool I've no water folks
was waiting for it you got jumped with
someone of Gideon Gideon Gideon has my
pleasure
I need to get the class but can I do you
want to have dinner tonight
like yeah like that
join us not what a lying sack of [ __ ]
he's like now that yeah ugly why when
I'm sober
if that Pretty Ricky play is that Pretty
Ricky that says little Wayne knowledge
yeah it's even worse it's even worse so
let me get this straight
hold up hold up come on point out heinie
so he she's like oh we want to grab dude
he's like yeah and then saman they
decide to use to convey the message of
like being consensual is a song about
men degrading women and and telling them
to suck their penis like it's a lollipop
that's a solid they used and then I'm
done nothing else I'm done well it was
well this [ __ ] makes no sense bro
there's one more to watch oh Jesus
Christ
again
[Music]
Hey Baby bounce for me oh hey hey girl
hey give us a smile baby no you know
what
well that's seriously you think that
that's gonna work for you
give me the compliments they love that
stuff I beat Friendly's not friendly
that's the thing man
it's just straight-up creepy you don't
know what you're talking about all right
ah can't even see my ass stop it stop
touching me no no II see what you
working that's not funny no I don't
actually I drop it I think your face
would look better without ya what
[Music]
the only reason of guys acting like that
is because the girl is ugly girls don't
don't ever do [ __ ] like that don't ever
try the cat call the guy
don't cat called guys especially guys
you don't want to get with why cuz he's
gonna get with you
that was the corniest acting I've ever
seen no dude with ever act like that if
you can't call me talking about hey can
I see your package will [ __ ] I'm about
to pull out my jump free and it's about
to be a hot garbage messy not about the
fling that [ __ ]
girls don't cat call guys cuz we will
say yes we will be like yes girl you can
sit on that face as long as I'm gonna
have a face you're gonna have a place to
sit on yes go I don't want to sniff your
your toilet seat when you get off I
think I'm a problem with you sitting on
my face girl
[Music]
and in that [ __ ] here and oh they
started looking away from each other
like aw [ __ ] I gotta actually talk to
this thing now
anyways all this was said I agree with
the message that cop-calling is wet I'm
fine with that
catcalling is way like there's guys out
there that call girls guys yeah yeah
shut the [ __ ] up with that [ __ ]
alright I get that with the video put
the ending Oh
feminism Rose you guys have failed
miserably if anything you've turned
people off from what you want to do
alright so that's it for today's video
if you guys like that be sure to LIKE
subscribe Facebook YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main bits follow
us on Instagram all that good stuff
we got a patreon page so if you want it
don't need a little bit of money you
know give us a little thumbs up then we
do it I definitely went the wrong
direction yo but that's it so you know
thanks holler a dollar makes me holler